the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok I was at the Atlanta yesterday and
attending a conference another expert
from the describe industry you know I
know her well and you remember I was
saying that they disk at a separation is
below 10 nanometers do you know how much
what's a separation now let's just say
about 1.5 nanometers yesterday that's it
that's what everybody has in a computer
it's amazing technology where are you
home I can push it right but the this is
this was actually a lab mate of mine and
she worked on nanoscale heat transfer
and see that's a perfect place because
what we're doing is the magnetic when
you make it a very small domain you
actually cannot a use a roamer magnetic
field it was flip T and magnetic domain
because otherwise the room temperature
just a spontaneous flips back so they
have to use very hard magnet magnet and
in that case they have to heat up the
domain so they have to heat up a nano
domain first and then apply magnetic
field to right so I thought I shared
this story with you talk a little bit
more about that technology later on we
will learn so coming back to last
lecture what we talked is a reciprocal
space that's a continuation and prove
the broad condition and that's the
when you do transmission like from
microscope or you do x-ray broad
condition is the one when you look at
the fraction patterns and then we move
down to discuss the energy of the atomic
vibration in crystals and so we
introduced photons right that's just so
they I say we solve the Newton's second
law is the first day is a continuum
approach it's a classic approach but the
treating the atoms as discrete and we
got the dispersion between the
vibrational frequency and we vector and
the wave vector is similarly as in the
case of electron are discretized have if
I have n atoms in the chain and I have
two pi over n this so the separation is
a 2pi over the lens of the crystal and
times a is the length of the crystal
right and we have acoustic branch and if
I have more than one atom at the lattice
point I have also after branch and the
acoustic branch has longitudinal and
transverse typically longitudinal has a
higher frequency and transverse nor
frequency and in the case of up
carefully this sometimes you can cross
over so it's hard to say which one has a
higher and lower but if I think if you
deal with the polar crystal like sodium
chloride and you have always a transfers
phonon lower and the longitudinal
follow-up to your phone or higher
frequency so what's important later on
is were simplifier models and one way to
simplify is the Debye so we try this
here although at the zoom boundary we
see you can see with careful in drawing
this almost like a perpendicular but say
while approximation we use
is approximately this by a street knife
that's the by model and the other is
what original Einstein proposes just a
constant frequency that's an Einstein
model and you can see that Einstein
model is closer for the update photons
order by model is closer for the say um
acoustic phonons so that's where we were
and with that if you recall what we have
talked to so far very fast right we
talked about energy levels first in
isolated atoms and molecules and that's
a vibrational translational and
electronic rotational and then we extend
to crystals and we view we say the
treatment the best treatment we die is a
one dimension and then we say okay what
today if you look at the three dimension
each direction has different pure this
day and different potential so your
curve may look different right and with
data you I hope you get appreciation for
the energy levels of electrons in solid
with data you can understand the why
they're the insulator whether
semiconductor were their medals right
and also you can now also have some
appreciation for the last vibration the
photons which is essentially here we do
a classical treatment but what photon is
a quantized form of this frequency at
each frequency for that mode you cannot
have any energy you can only have
discrete number powerful for long the
the energy is quantized right so those
are the this give us some picture what
has a quantum mechanical allowable
energy in matters and what we're we're
going to move is to add the temperature
because this is a quantum mechanical
allowable now if I have an object I
certain temperature what's the
statistical average right and what what
really what's the energy this object has
so that's where we're moving and but
before that I want to discuss a little
bit more of the counting right and if
you recall I said the we emphasize the
degeneracy a quantum state right quantum
state right is it defined by in the case
of all waves is if I have wave function
right in let's say I have my wave
function and KX KY KZ each of this KX KY
KZ so here in for example in one
direction I have this real number alpha
K values right each combination of K
value gives me one specific wave a wave
function right one wave function is if I
don't consider spin right electron I
have to say one wave function because of
the wave function itself doesn't include
spin so one that's one quantum state
okay and in the case of discrete atoms
we say quantum numbers right if you
recall when we do electronic states we
have and I am right that's the quantum
number and that we emphasize the quam
because is a different combination of an
LM could actually have the same energy
that's where we say this is how you
start understand the pure article table
right the degeneracy now if you look at
solid I'm only drawing in one direction
but we know that a real crystal solid
there is three directions and now if I
can't sir
frequency or certain energy if you think
about either frequency or energy because
a chi omega gives me energy
right and even in this same direction
you can see here I have all three states
three wave vectors right that can have
same quantum state right same energy C 3
we vectors three quantum staking have
same energy but if I look at the other
directions right many many other
directions I would have many other
possible states that could have the same
energy
so that's the degeneracy and that's
where I have to learn how to do that
counting okay so this is a major
emphasis today it's the idea of counting
today were really doing the density of
states and then when I say States I see
this is like basically of quantum states
okay
and I also hope at the end I have with
that how getting into quantum statistics
so this is a my plan today and let's
start we have looked at a very complex a
band structure for electrons for photons
this is I going to the Google and you
look at all those different images right
by say for the analytical purpose we're
going to look at a simple smaller like a
Debye model and for electrons we also
say if it's the other minimum of the
conduction band or the maximum of the
valence band we explain that near that
minimum
right so we'll have probiotic bands so
let's we need this so you feel recall
for electrons approximation and in the
simplest picture this is my K and K you
can single is the kxkykz and here is my
conduction band and I write this item in
with K equals zero minimum here and you
can put at a different point okay
and this curvature gives to me effective
mass so if I say this is the energy and
I expand this by the minimum then the
energy we vector relation right and here
is my you say the bottom here so energy
we worked our relation is the e say plus
h-bar K square divided by 2 and star
right so H Bar K we see under this
effective mass concept it's really just
like a day one half MV square because
the H K gives me momentum P P dy by mass
gives me C C it gives the velocity right
so that's the parabolic band
approximation and what we need to keep
in mind the K is vector in 3d space
right so K X we said if we in the X
Direction is 2 pi and times L X right
and again they at the end if I do all
this parabolic band approximation my
zoom boundary is here this is a PI over
a X right and the X is how many atoms
times disappeared an ax okay so let's
say L X equals n in the X direction I'm
pure yesterday in the X direction right
that's so simple 1d model just to make a
comment by passing now some of you
probably do working graphene see what's
special with graphene is that either
the bottom here the band here is not
quota I see a parabola it's accurate
straight line okay so a graphing
graphing the dispersion this is the
energy this is we vector and then your
small region near the Fermi level right
it's a zero gap so the band gap happen
to be zero and so at the Fermi level the
dispersion is a linear and that this
linear dispersion make the very similar
to the by model fofola and also photon
right photon is if you think about that
the model for photon is omega equals say
k right that's the speed of light and
for four lines Omega equals VK that way
is the by velocity sometimes with social
visit the sound velocity right so that
makes the electrons similar to photon
and similar to photons so that's what's
special with the graphene so this is KX
and of course I have seminary K by K Z
and the K square is a combination of KX
square plus KY square plus KZ square
okay so this means right my constant
energy surface if I give okay
is a constant energy is a constant right
kxkykz gives me a sphere so it's a
spheric or i'll say a constant energy
surface sometimes you draw real constant
energy surfaces in solid it looks very
complicated sometimes it look like a you
live sword or even other shapes
okay but I'm doing the simplest model
and so what you can say is there are
many combination of kxkykz
that could give me the same energy E and
each combination is a one quantum state
including a factor of two
if I think about spin right so this is a
the dispersion the energy with vector
relation is dispersion and for electrons
and for photons we already said Omega
equals VK that's what the by
approximation and K now that's the K for
we're for the electron order for the
photon wave vector but again based on
discussion we have those allowable
values right so and for photon Omega
equals the say K like I just written
down but I say this K for photon I don't
have a upper limit it's a I haven't
discussed so in free space this K could
be really large okay so those are the
dispersion between frequency we vector
or energy we vector all those we call
dispersion relations right now based on
I'm going to count how many states so it
turns out for example I want to count I
have any electrons right where is the
Fermi level if you recall when I did the
simple one-dimensional hydrogen atomic
chain right and we say this is the we
say this is a dispersion okay and I have
you turn here my supply over a 2 plus PI
over a symmetric and I have K points I
say if it's a 1d I go to the lowest
stage and because I have n states
between power they to minus PI minus PI
over 2 plus PI worry I have any
electrons and the each of this wave
function have a spin up spin down so I
feel to the middle right that's a 1d
case now if I ask the same question if
it's a 3d where does it go where is the
fini right and in that case because
there are many kxkykz combination K gave
me the same energy level so I have to do
this summation so this is the total
number of electrons there's a total
number of atoms right if I say hydrogen
each hydrogen give me one electron right
and then I have to sum up what I know is
let's say they add a zero temperature
the lowest energy is a filled first
right so I I have to think of this so
now rather than 1d I have to think about
3d 3-dimensional coordinate right and
you will feel to the lowest and to the
uppermost this is a recall
this is my EF right that's where my
Fermi level is and the corresponding e
this is my K if I say this isn't my KF
okay
and my motto is X Y Z or direction of
the same if you look at that what I read
and done right so KF so this is a commie
constant energy sphere and the constant
we vector are also at that location so
when they so each of this combination
kxkykz gives me one quantum state as
lies this quantum state lies below EF it
has one electron so I add up that hold
her should give me a total number of n
total I know electrons okay and recall
this is a huge number
right if I say one more of God will
cancel ten to twenty third okay it's a
it's going to be very large lumber
summation so what I have here is going
to I say K X so any of those allowable
values you know KF or that KX value
right Ichi
I have many points there I have K Y same
I have phase a right as long as this o
KX square plus KY square plus KZ square
is ways in this is KF square right so as
long as within this range that
combination all those combination give
me a quantum state that's filled right
so I have each K X K by D square point K
X K back
they gave me one quantum state except
that doesn't count spin so I have factor
of two right so each of this quantum
state has one electron right to plus KX
KY KZ combination that's a one electron
right the each of this so well I really
sign me up that one y electron you get
me I'm doing hunting it's basic counting
okay now if later on I'm not going to do
one I'm going to do half field at a
certain temperature for example some
states that couldn't be empty right so I
make as I say rather than one I may be a
probability we're very strong at the end
of lecture I hope I get there so this
will be a function of energy and
chemical potential and temperature right
here I'm doing my simplest case at zero
temperature any quantum state below the
Fermi level are filled and I have my
requirement that I have total and
electrons and I want to find out the
word is my KF where's my EF okay so now
you go to do a summation how you do this
summation right and doing summation when
it has many unless it's a simple series
it's not easy right so the way to do it
is convert that submission into an
integration that's what we're going to
do next and the condition for converting
a summation into integration right if I
have a function here right and remember
this is a page set of point is a one
value I'm summing up those values when I
do that summation right
and now if this function does not very
rapidly between the points it's like a
you do trapezoidal rule you can actually
do converted some some back into
integration so how we do it
okay let's say KX right if I have a
Delta KX right right or DK x when I do
integration I do it DK x right so how
many points that there are in DK x now I
look harder this spacing between two
adjacent point KX 2 pi n LX so what's
the spacing between two adjacent point
four by or X or X right so I do DK x
divided by 2 pi L X that's how many
points over d KX
okay so now I'm converting this one and
rather than sum over D cos a KX I do
integration over this is my integration
over KX so what's my limit if this is a
k xf m minus KX f right so I have minus
K F X plus K F X and remember I'm
leaning a symmetry right here negative
positive K symmetry okay and I do the
same d KY + 2 pi L y KF y KF y + KF z KF
z d kz 2 pi L Z and that integration is
over one that you probably don't like 1
Y is just to look too
also let me just put any function as I
said before right say later I when I say
they firmly I will come back to F equals
what so the F as a function of mu T
right and turns out this F could be any
function sometimes this F could be a
function of yeast sometimes this
function this could be a function of K
okay and most of the time when we do
what you always do instead of states
it's a function of U so you want come
where the function ye or your function
of frequency but when you do transport I
just want to warn you
we need to transport this function is
also a function of K so the way I do
that the summation sometimes in
transporter is actually not very useful
but it's such a common concept that's
used every every time you go to rate or
you discuss people say what's your task
what's the density of states okay so
this is I'm converting that of course I
have factor of two I have my end this is
the same I'm writing that summation into
integration and so now with this you can
say LX ly LZ gives me volume right and
two PI cubic so what I have is a two
volume two PI cubic and then say I have
an escape they the integration limit and
I what I have here is d KX d KY decays a
right
triple indigo so by this transformation
assume in this function f does not
change very rapidly Dapitan
adjacent point i have converted this
summation into integration and now I
have further freedom
because you see here if I give you this
function f in terms of yi yi is a
function of K so you have the freedom of
how you do an integration whether you
integrate in terms of E or in degree
interval K you have to come work relay
them right change it into the same
variable so you can do your integration
and also what I can do is here is what
I'm doing is in a Cartesian coordinate
DK XDK by DK j is a Cartesian coordinate
right
and if this is a spherical symmetric so
far if it's a function of EEE you can
say if it's fine here is very symmetric
right I don't have so if the function of
Yui for fula here Omega is okay so it
does not depend on so in that case it's
much easier if I do convert the KX KY KZ
into just okay in the spherical
coordinate right rather than to doing
triple integral I do just say TKD I
think if it's a twin spherical if it's a
this Y is not a function it's only
function of absolute value of K it's a I
so this is a 4 pi can you tell me huh k
square DK right try translating from a
Cartesian into spherical it so
everything of here is the math but
what's amazing is the people this is
such a convenient concept to talk about
right so here is the 4 PI K square DK
and then I can group this together
okay now I'm going to group this back
into here so that my I like to write an
over way by the many people see so this
in their case in my den subsidies per
unit volume so he ran over way then is
the integration integration and the F
here I combine what they were all inside
in tool you can say I have pie square K
square DK right and so here K is 0 2 KF
0 K because I'm doing spherical
coordinate my radius is 0 like if I
don't do like a do positive because
that's a Cartesian coordinate you see
what I'm doing okay so this one now is
my density of states this is a density
of states so it's a lamber of states per
unit interval of k right how many states
quantum state I have / Delta K right
because here and say in DK my
integration is in D K so then they stay
of states in if I write eyes in terms of
K that means there's a per delicate okay
but say if you go back to what I alluded
here if my F is the function of e then
you have to make your child choice
whether you want converter Yi in this
fell F into K or you are to come where
that DK into a function of e
right it's just your choice there's no
formula and so whatever is a
mathematical convenient for you so I
could also convert if I wanted to
convert into energy integration so I
will do EF and F so in that case I would
write this into a square PI Square D K
de and the de right at the end
everything in this blob I'm going to
convert writing in terms of e so I have
relation between K right and the e so I
can convert this K into EU so if I write
this in front in terms of e and I
integrate over e this is my density of
states per energy interval right here is
my lambo of states per day okay here is
my pencil stage / Delta e and I say
similarly you can rather your / Delta
Omega over Delta e over Delta lamda so
with that I wanna just to say you have
the you feel that it's a mathematic
concept and the case you can translate
you can start from here you can write
your submission and go through that I've
done that probably hundred times so now
I can I remember while earlier I was
good a book what's the formula given the
book but if you get comfortable with
that summation it's a translating
summation into integration and
particularly when later on when we do
like a boards my equation transport this
is going to a function of K X K Y K Z so
I do not actually do when I convert d k
XD k yd k ji to see the fire I do a
spherical coordinate but I don't have
the function itself do not have
spherical symmetry so I will have to do
in the general case
this one right if I do a spherical
corner inside sweetheart
DC ha D Phi D K and K square so this
will be my circle converting a unit
volume in Cartesian into a unit volume
in spherical right but we're not doing
them now when you do transport this is a
so common okay okay so that's they are
the concept of pinup states and let's
best use this concept and do a few
examples to get familiar more
comfortable so let's first look at that
they continue our Fermi level right and
I'm going to you can take in in this
case it depends on whether you take
where you take a reference you say right
here if I write it the way I'm writing
zero to EF integration is 0 to EF means
to zero the feeling star the equal zero
so in that case I cannot use the EC
because the return zero and they say
there's no energy state electron can now
feel between zero you see right so you
have to be careful when you write those
formulas and use yourself consistently
what's your reference where you're doing
your integration just a reminder
and if I do following what I have here I
have per unit volume I give you this
number of electrons and I want to find
that I the absolute zero temperature
where is the uppermost energy level
right so my band then e equals H u
square K square to M because my energy
start the finning start this is my e
this is my K I'm trying to find the word
is the EF right this is a the Fermi
level and so in that case what I have is
F equals 1 right that's below the Fermi
level all the energy each state is spin
up spin down so I have an N equals and
way equals 0 EF + 1 so the K square so
what's my K square now I need to convert
I want the converter into e ok this Y is
easy
that's my if I do in terms of K but I
want to do in terms of e and so what I
have K square is 2 m right so K equals 2
M star e over H bar square 1/2 and I've
based on the dispersion so I have 2 K
square is 2 m star e H bar square that's
my K square PI square so I will put a PI
square here and then I have my d KY de d
KY d this is Mike hey this is my e so my
DK de is
one half to M star H bar Square and D
KDE is this is a 1/2 + AE negative 1/2
so this is a overall integrate over de
now I'm going to erase this so what I've
written down is really what's the inside
this I can where the K into e I can wear
dige all right
it also internally so that I add I have
all that blob is my den substrate right
so here is what's my tents up States you
say 2m h bar squared at the three-halves
and so and the e and the e minus 1/2
so my density of states is if you I just
want to check everything is reading it
should be correct okay so what I have
here is a 2 pi square and M star 2m over
H bar square and three half and II must
say 1/2 so this is my den subspace and
this e is referring to my 0 is at the
bottom you see if I take my 0 at the
different location I have to do Iman CEC
okay so if you many many times when I
was just learning this I just to say
okay I forgot it a good I'm in the back
out to the book I do a derivation and I
plug in here
because at the end you want to do this F
times D and integrate the over energy by
say now I can comfortably sit there and
every time I forget that I say I redo my
summation to integration conversion okay
it takes many times so that's the tents
up stage right and of course now I want
to find out the word is EF right so here
if you if you see this is your year if
you put it in this tent set up States is
de d de right essentially what I have
here is 0 EF de de many times people get
familiar this is where they start right
I want to find out where the EF gave me
the number electron I write things up
state I integrate over E that's how many
states I have right each state I have
one electron so that's they how many
electron I have and with that you go to
do your integration you say this is a
constant you can take out it's really
1/2 integration over ye de + 2 0 - year
right so this will give you where's your
Fermi level you do your integration
you'll find out that your EF equals 3 PI
square and 2/3 + H + square 2 m that's
after you do your integration and in
your universe writing in terms of EF ok
any question here it's converting
submission into integration do the
correct accounting the density of states
tells you the lamber of quantum state
per energy interval per wave vector
interval frequency interval
I used to ride it okay so see like one
and just a comment right and let me
write the let me draw the tens'up stay
for electron this is the energy this is
de right and if I have energies right we
say this is the MICU say so i i i put on
my si not at the zero but at an
arbitrary point then this is a day
parabola tense up state that's the shape
of this top state because the square
root okay
that's because if you say at the bottom
there are not many states by the you
increase energy there are a lot more
state states that have similar energy
values okay so now let's do the same for
for long conceptually we follow the same
same process converting this summation
into integration
okay so I'm going to look at the phone
and I'm using the buying model and the
bad model say Omega equals wait times K
and this K is the magnitude of the wave
vector right so it's the square root of
KX square plus KY square plus KZ square
and also in this case the photons are
degenerate three polarizations
transverse to ninety two thousand one
and Tobiah just collapse the old is 3
into 1 9 there so but you should still
know there are three polarizations okay
so in that case if you go back to
starting from my summation whatever
function right and let's forget about
that what I'm going to integrate because
right now I don't have goal number good
stuff will F for you yet I'm going to we
need to go to the the d square
distribution to say to actually give you
a free sample right so I can work that
summation into integration saying but
the effect of two which is a spin for
electron need to become a factor of
three because I have a polarization
sweet the by model I have three
polarization right okay for each kxkykz
I have three polarization so as three
that's where my factor three so if you
look at my DK that's a where is my DK
here this is my tenth upstate decay
before it's a factor of two now at the
fact I was three so that should be
three halves of this so my decayed ends
up States for full-on is three halves
what I have here is the K square PI
square right now my D Omega is DK and
the DK D Omega so this is a written
eventually it has to be changed a into K
has to be changed into Omega right now
I'm going to do frequency integration I
fräulein I normally don't do de my
habita is a typical dou T Omega now I do
DK D Omega
right so DK D Omega also DK is three
half K is omega over way here square PI
Square and DK d Omega is one over weight
right okay
so with that I will get a three half pi
square V cubic Omega square so this has
been some states for funa
and here is D Omega and here is Omega so
it's a it's a day parabola it's not
square root tense up States for electron
is the square root of energy right here
is actually square of energy okay
so different dispersion give you
different density of states now this
could be easily converted into photon
photo
now a longitudinal electromagnetic wave
right only to polarization to transverse
waves okay and that two transverse wave
should not be three it should be two and
the speed of sound becomes speed of
light right so for photon density
upstate in terms of frequency is just
Omega square PI square say cubed okay
the best is so you see there and right
through all this and getting yourself
comfortable it's mathematics it's not
much really not much physics okay so
that's the case of for 3d structure now
let's do a 2d I'm doing okay so we say
let's look at a quantum well let's look
at a thin film what would be the
quantization in fact on the density of
states okay so let's do a 2d and put in
here
I'm going to a quantum well okay and
before when we talk about quantum well
we say just a one dimensional quantum
well now I'm going to give you more
realistic a feel right in the case of
theorem electron can move in X Y Z three
dimension and so if I have a film and in
the thickness direction I have LZ okay
and in the XY direction I have free
movement I don't have constraint right
so my energy relation will be K X K Y in
the XY direction I have this great point
as whether we have before but say that 2
pi LX 2 pi L Y right that's my
separation but my LX ly in the XY
direction are millimeters or right
that's a macroscopic so that separation
is very small on the Z direction I'm on
Strong's Henry Antrim right
so in that case recall that when we
discuss the energy in this direction is
standing wave right so and they and let
me just use n lambda over 2 equals LZ
right and that means lambda equals LZ 2
divided by
and you can convert this back into
energy right HPSA the momentum K equals
two PI over lambda and what do you have
here 2 PI over lambda lambda is there so
I have M PI over L Z right and the
separation between this is my K it is
either a separation is become PI over L
Z now if you look at that the separation
we say in the unconstraint case KX the 2
pi L x over n right so in the
unconstraint case I have plus minus and
that the separation is a 2 pi over l LX
in the constraint case I have n is only
pass okay and the separation is a PI
over L Z is the set is a factor of 2
difference that's because I'm using a
traveling wave this is a traveling wave
positive-negative the ratchet to
construct a standing wave right so it's
actually equivalent the whether I use
past - in the case or whether I use
standing way but in the case of small
length L say I had to look either this
separation because that summation cannot
be converted into integration so this is
the difference so if I write in that
case I'll write my energy is H square
say KX square plus KY square that's in
day so effective mass in the implant
direction in the X Y direction okay and
in the Z direction and I have if I use
this I can do my energy quantization
right is a HK / HK squared divided by 2
so 1/2 m HK square H square K square is
M PI over LZ square right and of course
1 2 ok so this is my energy level I'm
still writing H square KZ square KZ
squared now I do a standing wave and
because my LZ is very small so between
the two and consecutive n there could be
many kxky ok so if you look at this what
I what I have here recall in a 3d right
a spherical I say we say a constant
energy surface is a sphere right now I
have a constant energy surface is the XY
plan is a circle but then depends on the
in value I have jumps different values
okay it depends on the different energy
so the other way to think about this n
equals 1 so you this is a word we do a
quantization in fact this is a you say
before that's a foul alright that's a
balk of course I'm only talking 1 the
Russian ok but that you have to think of
this as K X K Y Z is alike so you do a
rotation alright so here and they wanna
have quantization it turns out that the
minimum energy now can no longer be here
because N equals 1 that gives me the
first level right so the bottom of the
conduction bandage will shift up right
so that's why sometimes people will say
how I can open a gap well how
quantization
I can cut official return you can see my
medal
into a semiconductor let me give you one
one idea for example when work on
thermoelectrics there is a material
business turns out build my season like
this right it's a similar model they
there's no gap this is the table of
valence bottom conduction and convection
valleys below valence pan so in this the
Fermi level is around here and there's
no gap it's a Simha medal right so
mellow is not good for thermoelectrics
and because when electron in this host
in this they still have you can still
have the electron holes and when they
diffuse to same the ration the heat they
cancel each other so it's not good so
how we can create a bandgap out of this
material and you do a size effect so you
make it a smaller and theoretically what
happens is this one is a function of
alpha diameter or sickness so this will
move up depending on thickness this one
will move down right so now you can
create a gap and there also discussion
for example silicon right silicon is
like what you have here this is the day
it's an indirect gap the valence band is
here conduction band is here right there
is another conduction band but it's not
it's not a minimum this is the minimum
so now what do you do you make a very
small task and this will move up of
course this will move down and this also
move depends on the speed of moving
that's related to the mass right and
this could be moved to here and this one
move slower so this you can convert into
de rigueur
right so that's the beauty of this and
thinking about this quantum size the
fact you can use that to tune the band
gap of the materials and that's a when
you make a say like quantum dots like
cat Tara right Oh cat sulfite can now
Catterick house sulfite or if you look
at a professor mu nu / windiest website
that he has all this beautiful thoughts
different colors and that's because the
same material you change the size you
can actually open make a different gap
okay so those are aggression because I'm
come back to I want to find that what's
the dense Upstate right so let me again
start with okay i have here is a number
of electrons I gave to this and how much
how many electron in the material and I
still do my K X K Y mic hazy my F
whatever F I have their function that
I'm interested in integrating right and
in 3d I said this F is a very slow
function of K X K Y KZ so I converted
into integration but in 2d in the Z
direction right between two consecutive
so this is ESA and my first energy level
is here my second energy level is here
between this tool there are many K X K Y
there are many states in between K X K Y
right
so I cannot convert in the Z Direction
into summation integral integration I
need to keep that summation and now what
I could do is only come where the X Y
Direction into integration so
this is what I'm going to do I'm going
to tape my say summation in the
x-direction I can still do so I have DK
x 2 pi ax and y the ration I still do
DK y 2 pi o y and z direction I cannot
do I'm going to keep my summation and
rather than K Z I can also do n it's the
equivalent whether you do an notation on
kz notation right and whatever F I have
factor of 2 m of the inside right so now
rather than to a 3d Cartesian coordinate
your mathematics is in 2d kxky
integration so you do either polar
coordinate or so it depends on your f
whatever your f f is the function of yi
or right so that's your choice
but let me I'm going to do here you say
I have area LX x ly and if I do d KX d
KY I convert it into a polar coordinate
right d KX v KY you know polar if it's
symmetric is 2 pi K DK right let's say K
I I just make it notation KX square plus
KY square so it's 2 DK parallel so in
this case I have 2 pi K parallel D K
parallel and that's the d KX d KY and
then I have 2 pi square that's here 2 pi
square then I have another tool
summation and F right you see I'm not
the jump into this up state I'm deriving
the start state I'm comfortable doing
that just converting the the concept
that just converting my summation into
in degrees
and what I can do right if I my F is the
energy so I can write my K parallel also
in terms energy all right so now like go
back to the dispersion let's say this is
a this I let me not make a notation this
is my en right let's add a sub levels of
quantized in Z direction and this is my
K parallel square so my I can write this
my K
Carlos square equals to M star H bar
square Yi my cen right so I have really
you can say here I need to convert if I
want to write into in terms of de I need
to convert this K parallel into energy
and that I need odk parallel de ok so if
you do your math if you go to look at
what do we have there
what I have is so this is a 2 pi 10 so
one and two kinds of one have another PI
right so I have integration one over pi
sigma whatever and F and now I need to
write here K parallel in fact if I put
this in I do the DK square parallel
squirt because DK parlor square I have
it here right so I have a DK parallel
squirt that means I have 1/2 I have to m
bar star and the edge Square and D not
sure whether you're following my
conversion I'm writing this in to e K
parallel the pair based on what I have
here and of course I have a summation
and that means when Yi he has to be
larger than Yin right otherwise this is
a say I say you can say if I do if it's
Yi is less than e and my K parallel will
be imagine okay so what I have here all
this blah blah FF is the one that I want
to integrate my density of states is
this tensor the N and M star and H
square and I have another PI and that's
my dense Upstate okay it's a step
function N equals 1 and of course 2 you
add another one and you go 3 you had
another one right so what I have here is
if I draw all this is my Yi and say
I have and this is this is my V 1 u 2
that's the quantization energy level
this ray is step function and before we
draw the electron you go check your
loads this is a parabola right this is
like a you say that's they - that's a 3d
this is 2d so you see now that their
difference in these substrates and once
you go to quantized mode you've got a
more sharp features right step function
and you go to wire you gotta actually
some delta function the thoughts we've
got a delta function it's this kind of
we'll step and Delta or line that give
you some very peculiar cara sticks for
the quantum systems okay any questions
it's math okay it's a counting now no no
complicated physics yes buzzer yeah so
the right way to write is I write a
Heaviside function so have said there's
a step function okay
okay this is so we spend most of today's
lecture in doing the counting and say
how I really is a converting summation
into integration and if the function
doesn't change much over the summation I
can convert in the condoms case in the
direction quantization that conversion
is usually you have to be careful you
you probably cannot do that conversion
because there is a large change of that
function in the summation direction and
what we go in next is do this F okay and
particular we're doing our system a
certain temperature and what's the
answer in the question at the one
quantum state each quantum state for
example what's the average number of
electron because it could be zero on one
but at certain temperature there's a
statistical average what's that lumber
the same for falling right I can have
zero one infinite then the what's the
average number of falling for each
quantum state now I know how to how I
can count quantum state right how many
quantum state I have what I want to say
next is either H constant how many
electrons how many photons given a
certain temperature now I'm going to get
into a thermal system right and how much
energy you have so let me give a very
see a beginning of that and in fact if
you recall we did in the first chapter
we give you the boys man factor right so
this is my condom statistics
and in the first chapter beginning we
say the board's man factor gives you the
probability of a particle we were not
we're not discussing whether it's
quantum or classical probability of
particle have a certain energy a certain
temperature is a low Malaysian factor
minus a exponential e KBT I said take it
this is the the boys man factor right
you've seen many many say examples of
this sports man factor see the energy
barriers Arrhenius no all this is
related to the boards man factor and
next lecture I hope I give you a little
rationale of this ok there is a
beautiful statistical framework to do
that and say we use this and then we
went to the Maxwell distribution right
if I have particle that has an energy
one-half M way x squared plus three Y
square plus VZ square right I say okay I
normalize this I put in here and the a
party girl has the probability between
minus infinity of class the influence of
what so with that I find that a
normalization factor that's how I get a
Maxwell distribution right so you see in
that process I did not consider the
discontinuity of the velocity any value
between minus infinity to plus infinity
now I'm going to do a liberator
say discontinuous right I'm going to ask
you for example if I have a quantum
state electron is it in thermal
equilibrium with surrounding
the temperature T right and you liked
wrong say say what's the average so this
is a now I'm looking at a one quantum
state right
it's the in thermal equilibrium with
sarandí I'm asking question what's the
probability of this quantum state how
many electron it has right so that's the
question I'm asking
and now the difference of that question
there are two difference compared to
here what is that electron in that
quantum state that you can go the
electron can be in that one step or jump
out into the surrounding so I have mass
transfer a charge transfer whatever
right it's an open system so that's what
second is that electron that comes that
can only have a zero and one disagree
okay so when I have here words my factor
is the full closed system at constant
temperature and the one idea always open
system at a constant temperature
I had to modify this so I'm going to
give you again just a way for next
lecture
see the Gibbs factor and Gibbs factors
for open system and the probability of a
system open system has certain energy
and certain number of particle as either
temperature T is a again normalization
mass the energy of the system mastered a
Lambro particle times this constant mu
and divided by KBT so now I add this mu
which is the chemical potential that's
to say how much energy you need to take
out or place a particle into the system
that's a chemical potential
okay so mu is the chemical potential
and that's the same tango potential is
essentially they gives free energy and
it's a it's a it doesn't include this
the entropy part and gives free energy
difference gives you how much work you
can get out of the system okay so with
that I'm considering one isolated
electron a quantum state this is the
easiest so I have one quantum state of
electron right this is the solution you
had before in continent from either for
solid or for molecule or for Adam right
you have this solution of quantum state
this is what we've been doing the
question is whether there is electron in
that quantum state or not so what's the
probability it's a 0 or Y right let's
say these are the two states when N
equals 0 or 1 well N equals 0 you and O
you have that quantum state that state
doesn't have real electron there doesn't
have energy so the energy and when this
is 0 this is 0 and when you have one
particular that energy that state has
energy I right so yeah I now I use this
two possibility I do my llamas engine
factor for the gifts factor so add up it
has to be has to be either 0 1 right the
ad Apple has to be 1 so when it's 0 p 0
0 T plus C here is AI 1
that has to be one so the first one zero
zero that's just a the second Irwin aye
aye so I have mass E I mu times n is
just mu KB T equals one so this gives me
a equals exponential mastery I nice meal
KB T plus one that's myeloma zation
factor Hey
right now my average lumber of
particular F average lumber which is the
average number of n right
once I have distribution probability I
can find the average any-quan' the
average energy every Labour Party or
whatever average you want right so that
should be zero because zero times this p
0 0 T plus 1 I have one part of your
hands p/e I won t so that's my average
number of particle right because this is
the probability when I e i-140 empty and
you go did you know your a you know your
P a times this AI mule and so you can
see this one and this one is the same
right in the numerator I have this one
in the denominator I have this one but I
have them plus factor one right so I
divide this so I can write a simpler and
you will see now what I have is e I mass
mill KB T plus 1 and this is the famous
Fermi Dirac distribution
okay so answer in three steps right you
gather if you take that energy
quantization probability normalization
you got from a drop and the next lecture
we'll get will go few more step put
together Bose Einstein distribution for
four lands these are four electrons